uh bruce arians has an offense found it
on the premise of no risk at no biscuit
he wants to push the ball down the field
to get the ball down the field the
quarterback has to hold the ball and
mike reese of espn.com had an intriguing
stat over the weekend from
2007 through 2019 now aryans didn't
coach in 2018 but during that window his
offenses generated 508 sacks of
quarterbacks during that same window for
tom brady and he didn't play in 2008 due
to the acl tear so it kind of evens out
he was sacked 318 times so that's 190
more sacks for bruce arians quarterbacks
during that window
and that's not good news for tom brady
because we've seen him trying to avoid
hits the last few years he's 42 going on
43 and uh he's concerned that if he gets
hit by a guy half his age he may get
injured how do you reconcile that in the
brucerian's offense chris yeah well i i
mean it's something that i think brady's
just gonna have to learn to wrap his
head around it a little bit here in the
off season to know okay maybe i need to
put on five or ten pounds of extra armor
here to stand in the pocket make throws
down the field that byron left which and
bruce aryans expect but you're right you
know hey listen if there's one thing i
was i'll ever be critical about with
bruce arians is his quarterbacks do get
hit too much you know that has always
been an issue or a concern for me brady
yes that's as you just said has been an
issue or concerned with me watching film
especially the last half of the season
where i felt like there was times where
i was reluctant to hold it on hold onto
the ball and take those shots so it's a
worry but mike that goes back i think
again to what we were just talking about
this is some of the things i think brady
will infuse into his offense and i think
that bruce arians and company will be
very willing and accepting of it i think
honestly some of the edelman wes welker
over the metal over the middle quick
throws are something bruce arians i
don't think is real diverse in his
offense and i think those are things
he'll be saying oh you want to put this
in tom sure teach me how you did this
all all these years in new england show
us how you did it and i think that'll be
an element added to the offense to you
know one keep defenses off balance but
another way to get the ball out of
brady's hand and something he's very
comfortable with
and it's going to be a challenge to
implement those kinds of things if there
is no off-season program or if the
off-season program that happens is
limited or if a lot of what occurs is
done kind of like this show today via
facetime i can envision meetings between
coaches and players ultimately happening
april may june through computer
connections and with film being shown on
a laptop whatever the case may be but
the opportunities to get on the field
and learn how brady does things how
bruce arians does things they're not
going to have as many as they ordinarily
would have had which is going to make it
more difficult to make the transition
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports